it's great to welcome back to the
program today Ben Cohen who is the
co-founder of Ben & Jerry's and also a
national co-chair for Bernie Sanders
2020 campaign
he's known Bernie for for a long time
right I mean how long have you known him
at this point uh you know I guess I've
known Bernie for about 40 years Ben and
Jerry started out at about the same time
that he won a very improbable victory
over a old crony democratic party
machine mayor and became mayor of
Burlington and what would you say has
changed from 2016 to 2020 in terms of
either the issues the personalities the
name recognition I mean how is 2020 for
Bernie different than four years ago
well one of the interesting things about
Bernie is that he has been incredibly
consistent in his beliefs in his values
and in what he's been promoting in terms
of what would be good for the country
for those last 40 years
but since 2016 I think the big
difference is that his name recognition
is huge and you know clearly he's
already leading the country based on all
the other candidates that have been kind
of following the positions that he
staked out in 2016 you know I firmly
believe that if the media gave Bernie
the same amount of coverage they gave
Trump in the 2016 election that Bernie
would be President today so I think this
time around he's starting off way ahead
of the game
in terms of name recognition in terms of
you know an organization a campaign
organization he's way way ahead he was
kind of building on the fly last time
around so you know those of us
working on the campaign or feeling
really really good yeah one of the
things I've been talking about is that
thanks to Bernie a lot of ideas that
were not common ideas in the Democratic
field in 2016 have been significantly
mainstreamed so whether they really
support it or not most of the Democratic
candidates now or at least paying lip
service to the idea of Medicare for all
or some other system that will achieve
full coverage when we talk about tuition
free public colleges and universities
there's a lot of issues that we can
thank Bernie for mainstreaming four
years ago but what I wonder is whether
the fact that those ideas have been
mainstreamed in some way hurts Bernie by
making the ideas no longer unique to
Bernie in the Democratic field well you
know it's interesting I think that being
authentic and being the originator goes
a long way with the public clearly
Bernie isn't just jumping on the
bandwagon he's promoting ideas that he
has deeply believed in and deeply fought
for for these past 40 years so I think
we welcome all these other candidates
supporting these incredibly good policy
initiatives and I look forward to Bernie
coming out with even more and better
ones
did you see the Town Hall that Bernie
did on CNN I guess now it was a couple
of weeks ago no I didn't you didn't okay
so I'll frame the question I glad I
asked so I can frame the question
correctly do you feel as though so far
the Democratic National Committee is
interfering in the primary in any way
similar to what we saw in 2016 or do you
believe that they are staying out of it
to the extent of picking a favorite or
leaning on someone or against somebody
else what's your assessment of their
presence and role in the primaries
so far I believe the primary so far you
know is just barely getting underway and
I think the DNC has been even-handed you
know I certainly am aware that there's
there's kind of two wings and the
Democratic Party one continues to be the
Hillary wing and you know I I imagine
that there's a lot of people on the DNC
that are that are in that wing which i
think is now going to become the Biden
wing but you know thanks to an
incredible amount of work by a whole lot
of people since the last Democratic
convention there have been some very
significant changes in the DNC you know
particularly in terms of super-delegates
not being able to vote on the first
round of voting at the convention and
and I also think that since the since
since their finger on the scale or shall
I say they're they're huge foot on the
scale was exposed last time around I
think they're a lot more sensitive to to
making sure that doesn't happen this
time yeah I hope you're right it's sort
of sad that it took this shameful public
thing that took place in order for some
of these rules to be changed and and for
hopefully things to be moved around but
I guess it's it's it's better than not
having the changes what one way or the
other you mentioned Joe Biden let me
talk about Joe Biden a little bit as I
told my audience last week Bernie
Sanders right now
is leading basically every poll for the
2020 Democratic primary specifically
among candidates who have declared Joe
Biden has not declared as of when you
and I are talking right now but in just
about every one of those polls Joe Biden
is polling ahead of Bernie
now there's one interpretation of those
poll
which is that's basically name
recognition and if Biden declares as
soon as people realize he's not actually
that progressive his support will go
down the other side is if if Joe Biden's
doing this well now when he declares
he's gonna run away with it
what do you think I think clearly the
the energy amongst the Democratic
rank-and-file actually get out there and
volunteer and work for candidates and
that donate small dollar donations to
candidates is in favor of Bernie and the
progressive wing of the of the
Democratic Party you know there's no way
that Biden is ever gonna turn out the
kind of crowds that that Bernie has
turned out and and actually if you look
at the most recent poll which I think
was by Emerson College amongst Wisconsin
voters Bernie even comes out ahead of
Biden specifically in within Wisconsin
you're saying that's correct
okay yeah I haven't I haven't seen that
one what do you think is responsible for
the strong polling numbers of Joe Biden
I think it's name recognition you know I
I think that you know if you just look
at even even Republicans and Democrats
everybody is saying we don't want
Washington insiders and Biden is you
know kind of the ultimate Washington
insider you know I have no doubt that he
will get a large hunk of big money
donations but big money donations also
known as bribery is not
what's going to sway the the voting
public this time around what will they
be swayed by will it be a particular
issue will it be personality will it be
who can best go up against Donald Trump
which is a consideration for some voters
well I think getting Donald Trump at
office as Bernie himself has said is
essentially job one and I think the way
to do that is to energize a huge base of
supporters and you know kind of mizzling
middle-of-the-road kind of centrist
policies is is not gonna do that you
know the other interesting thing is that
there's a significant overlap between
Trump voters and Bernie voters really
and and yeah and and it's not surprising
if you just listen to Trump's election
rhetoric last time around he was for the
little guy he was for the working people
he was not going to cut your Social
Security well Ben Heywood is it fair to
say I don't interrupt is it fair to say
Trump claimed to be those things maybe
is more precise exactly he claimed to be
those things and voters that wanted
those things had a choice of either
Trump the insurgent or Hillary the
establishment status quo business as
usual politician and and so they they
voted for God anything but the status
quo this time around I think Trump
voters many of them have seen that the
rhetoric does not match the reality and
if they truly want somebody who's out
for the interests of of the little guy
it's burning okay let's talk about
something that in some left-wing circles
I guess you're not supposed to talk
about but I really want to talk about it
with you particularly because of how
long you've known Bernie which is the
contingent of 2016 Bernie supporters
that either voted for a third party
candidate for Donald Trump or stayed
home now just so you know because you
may you know we our conversation was
years ago I supported Bernie Sanders in
the primary and ultimately cast a vote
for Hillary Clinton in Massachusetts
where I live in 2016
question one are you concerned about
that contingent in 2020 question two
what do you think drives that decision
to support Bernie Sanders in the primary
and then to do something other than
voting for the Democratic nominee when
it gets to the general election well to
support Bernie Sanders in the primary I
certainly understand that one okay
or you're suggesting you're positing the
the situation whereby Bernie does not
win the primary and and then would
people who voted for him in the primary
vote for a different Democrat it's not
so much I'm having it I'm sort of
thinking back to the small contingent
that did that in 2016 and the sort of
distant what maybe disproportionate
coverage of them given their actual size
well I think well firend last time
around nobody thought there was a chance
in hell that Trump was going to get
elected yes so they they didn't see a
vote you know they didn't see sitting
though sitting the election out creating
the problem that we've got today this
time around it's going to be pretty
clear to everybody that if you sit it
out we've got the the same horror that
we have today and ain't nobody gonna be
sitting in this election out yeah I
think that's a fair point I mean there
were some people last election who said
if it's not someone truly progressive
it's it's Hillary or Trump yes they're
sort of different but by and large it's
not effectively different now that we
see what's happened with the Supreme
Court we're seeing what's happened with
climate change or ignoring actually the
threat of climate change we're seeing
what's happening with the swamp feeling
you're suggesting that nobody at this
point would think that it's sort of
irrelevant who wins if it's not a truly
progressive candidate like Bernie that
people would realize the importance of
participating and voting no matter who
the nominee is well and and Bernie has
said it in so many words
that's four that he support whoever the
Democratic nominee is that the most
important thing we can do for our
country is to get Trump out of office
what is next for the campaign in terms
of messaging and strategy we know lots
of Bernie's most important issues
Medicare for all is sort of at the
forefront there what what shifts can we
expect in terms of the focus on issues
if any in the coming months you know I'm
not really aware of much that's coming
down the pike I mean you this is like
the question that I always get about
what's the new flavor coming out you
know if I knew I couldn't tell you you
know but I but I think what is really
different this time around and what what
is really exciting to me this time
around is the the diversity in terms of
race and gender and ethnicity in
Bernie's team and it is so wonderful to
be working with my fellow co-chairs
yulian the mayor of Puerto Rico Roe
Khanna and Indian by ancestry a
congressperson from
California and our the queen of the
co-chairs Nina Turner senator Nina
Turner from Cleveland an
african-american woman and it's it's a
beautiful thing to see and you know and
and I'm just so excited about the way
that Bernie has embraced diversity well
we have been following the campaign
closely and of course we will continue
to do it we've been speaking with one of
Bernie Sanders 2020 campaign national
co-chairs Ben Cohen really appreciate
you talking to me once again been good
talking to you David